I think you're going to find this interesting.
I've talked to you before about the important
distinction between a TV lawyer and a courtroom
lawyer.
For a while now, we have been referring to
Rudy Giuliani as Donald Trump's television
lawyer for a long time.
He goes on TV and he represents Donald Trump,
but he defends Trump in a way that's different
than what you would see in a courtroom.
Many of the things that a TV lawyer can say
are different than what an actual courtroom
lawyer would say.
You can't make the same claims in front of
a judge that you would potentially be making
on television.
These two worlds collided and exploded in
dramatic fashion this week because it was
announced on Sunday or Monday that Rudy would
be representing Donald Trump in court, in
court in Pennsylvania in one of these completely
bogus voter fraud cases.
And Rudy Giuliani actually was going to be
expected to behave the way.
A courtroom lawyer behaves rather than a television
lawyer, and what's just fascinating about
that is that when Rudy Giuliani was directly
pressed by the judge in Pennsylvania about
whether he is actually alleging that voter
fraud took place, Rudy Giuliani said, I am
not alleging that this is it's so important
to understand this because it's not just Rudy
Giuliani.
This has happened with numerous Trump lawyers
in court in filing these various briefs and
motions and complaints when they've been asked,
are you alleging actual voter fraud?
They all say no.
And it's just perfect because Rudy went in
with all sorts of vague claims that left leaning
counties conspired to hurt Donald Trump will
hold a vote.
What does that actually mean?
Happened, though?
He went in with claims that absentee voting
was unfairly administered in some counties
versus others.
But when it came down to it, he was asked,
are you alleging fraud in court?
And Rudy said, no, your honor, we are not.
And then he went on to say, well, we believe
the process was fraudulent, which is kind
of a distinction without a difference.
But it's still relevant, Rudy, when put in
front of a judge rather than in front of Judge
Jeanine Pirro on Fox News, who's just the
TV host in front of an actual judge in a court
of law, he can't actually say we are alleging
specific fraud.
Instead, he says, we believe the process was
generally fraudulent and led to, I guess,
what he sees as the wrong results, which is
that Donald Trump lost.
This is the final confirmation we needed that
even they know when they alleged fraud took
place in public, they don't really believe
it, or at least they recognize they don't
have the evidence to claim that that's what
took place in front of an actual judge in
a court of law.
Now, Rudy wasn't exactly perfect during the
court appearance.
He did stop short of saying we are alleging
fraud because they aren't actually.
But he did at one point suggest that some
kind of democratic mafia stole the election
from Joe Biden.
There's no evidence of that whatsoever.
Rudy also apparently committed perjury.
Rudy Giuliani submitted a petition to the
court in which he wrote that he is a member
in good standing of the Washington, D.C.
Bar Association, when in reality, Rudy Giuliani
is currently suspended from the D.C. bar because
get this, he didn't pay his dues to the Washington,
D.C. bar.
Isn't that just perfect? Trump doesn't pay
his contractors and lawyers worry Trump's
not going to pay them.
And Rudy didn't pay to remain part of the
D.C. bar, which led to him perjuring himself
when he told the Pennsylvania court that he
was a member in good standing of the D.C.
bar.
Now, that's an aside.
The question is, if you are not alleging fraud,
why are you here to make general points about
elections?
Because it sure as hell seems like you're
here to try to overturn the results of the
Pennsylvania election.
And these lawyers that Donald Trump has working
for him are not going to be able to get past
any judge with a reasonable understanding
of what they're doing.
And so far, that's why everything is getting
thrown out by court after court after court.
And by the way, speaking of judges, this is
why the Republican Party has been one hundred
and ten percent focused pedal to the metal
during Donald Trump's presidency on getting
as many loyalists into federal judge positions
as possible.
They know that on a lot of issues, the law
is not on their side.
So they prepare to corrupt the law by putting
in place their cronies.
And I hate to admit it, they've succeeded
to a great degree.
I've talked about this before.
Mitch McConnell, I think, is a despicable
guy.
If you are a Republican, you see Mitch McConnell
and you recognize this is the guy who has
done an amazing job of installing hundreds
of judges.
Oh, I mean, if you go pre Trump, it could
even be maybe it's even over a thousand, I
don't know, endless judges who are going to
continue ruling in a partizan way, whether
you've got a Democrat or a Republican in the
White House, as we are very quickly going
to see during the first couple of years of
the Joe Biden administration, they have done
a really good job.
I think they're horrible.
I think these judges are horrible.
But if you are them, you have to look at Mitch
McConnell and say this.
This guy has been incredibly successful.
And while the Trump scandals continue to rage,
they keep putting judges in judges.
They didn't even stop during coronavirus.
And it is something that we will have to contend
with for a long time in the United States.
And listen, if they had gotten more of them
in, you might have actually seen some of these
court cases about supposed voter fraud, a
go in Donald Trump's favor.
Maybe some still will.
For now, they have not.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman so you can
also follow me at David Pakman.
We will take a quick break and be back with
much more